[Music]
thank you everyone
um something a little bit different but
I think necessary this year like to
begin tonight's program by acknowledging
that we gather as settlers on the
occupied traditional lands of the Alamo
Aulani people
[Applause]
including the villages known as cutler
nook sitll intok choo-choo e-book talk
tip sente and opera moe whose sights are
within the boundaries of today's city of
San Francisco while tonight we'll see
images of many landscapes and human
works that are no longer with us
the aloni people are not lost they are
still present on this great peninsula
and we live among them today we live in
a time of weaponized amnesia but as we
look to history and memory as resistance
to willful forgetting let's not take
refuge in an unrestorable past the
spirits of tonight's event may be about
the past but our mandate is to think
about the future and about what kind of
San Francisco we'd like to live in so
finally I think as you know you are the
soundtrack your responsibility is to
make this into a unique and
irrepressible show and put your stamp on
it I'm going to give you some background
there's a lot of very interesting things
for me to say about the film clips but
you have the floor please
raise your voices and make this
screening your own
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so what we know about this film most of
what we know now is for through the work
of David keen of the Niles sna film
museum who actually found out that it
was the Myles brothers and it was shot
before the quake because this car
license number for 867 was registered in
early April of oh six before that I was
thought this one was made in oh five
[Music]
oh gosh you don't go online there's tons
of stuff now that's been unearthed about
them David did early research in
newspapers and found out that they had
there was an announcement that they'd
rented a special work car from the
railway company so that they could mount
the the camera on a on an open platform
[Music]
[Applause]
you notice that car comes up again and
again this is the Myles Brothers adding
a little drama seriously
[Music]
I hear Stockton in third
[Applause]
there's a this morning Rick lobster of
the Market Street Railway suggested in
an email that all of the the streetcars
you see coming in the other direction
the cable cars that it's much more than
they ever put in service and he thinks
that the railroad company did this to
show off so this is a new working
hypothesis
so if any of you are attempted to make
your own version of this the full 4k
file as on the Internet Archive and it's
freely downloadable it's 86 gigabytes so
clear out your hard drive
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
see the horse cars on the far track
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
on the top floor of one of San
Francisco's most beautiful buildings
with a phenomenal view of the city of
sevengills
is one of the most fabulous
organizations in the West
through these portals pass well come on
bestie it's early in the morning these
people believe in that old slogan early
to bed and early to rise and take the
suckers who advertise one the potencies
asked of a new day with speed and
boundless anything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
1939 and this is the construction of the
bay bridge through the courtesy of Don
lovest on who I believe is with us
tonight
[Applause]
the smart ones stayed behind
so the the the Western Anchorage of the
bridge many of you have been passed it
on the Embarcadero was built in to
Rincon Hill which was it had been to
some extent leveled before but it was
leveled and cut through for the bridge
Anchorage and I'm preparing you for some
more images of Rincon Hill in a minute
but in the meantime we're going to just
see a couple more stages of construction
this is South of Market imagine the
difference between now and then
this is probably about 1936 just before
I guess a year before the bridge oh no
the year the bridge opened but early in
the year
these construction sites you see so and
here's Treasure Island being filled in
this is what we have to be afraid of
being filled in for the Golden Gate
International Exposition 39 and 40 and
the key system mol where the trains went
to the East Bay and I've used this shot
before but it's just one of my favorites
it's during World War two and it's the
approach to the bridge from Harrison
Street I believe and if you notice
there's this great sign no photographs
from the bridge well of course they're
transgressing and taking pictures of the
military secrets so this is the Yura
family through the courtesy of Leslie or
other your family lived on Rincon Hill
and they're outside the canal exposition
ravioli company and I think their
laundry is their laundry
this is 1336 Grant Avenue and this is
from 1928 now your family lived on
Rincon Hill and I want you to take a
close look when we shift locations
because they're living on the equivalent
of 2nd or 3rd Street on the cystal grant
and it's semi rural up there somewhere
around maybe 3rd and Harrison 3rd and
Bryant today
so they're leaving house for a picnic
and this is the top of Rincon Hill in
1928 II could see the telephone building
in the background I think
and in Golden Gate Park
and we're seeing Toru a euro and Norma a
euro and Shizuko your siblings this is
the father if Leslie has made the film
available and yahiko here and akiza
Frankie or less Lee's grandparents I
think some of the euros are in the
audience tonight
[Applause]
and this is in the background I think
you see is that the sticker the Schmidt
lithography tower near the bridge near
Bryant and something or other
you know what the Yura family did is
they shot films for their relatives in
Japan and their relatives in Japan shot
films for them and they exchanged them
they were expensive in today's dollars
an hour of filming processing is about
fourteen hundred dollars but more people
can you think okay this was shot by
Henry or Hank Gomez
I believe mr. gomez is in the audience
and this is his journey to work from
Ingleside Terrace to the Standard Oil
Building where he works it worked as an
architect in about 1975 if I read that
correctly so I think there's 11 members
of the Gomez family here tonight art
opened up in San Francisco in 1973
the almost spanking-new Embarcadero
Center
and a brief shot of Chinatown in the
International Settlement from somewhere
else some home movies I think in the
late 30s early 40s and a feature outtake
from an unknown film
I think it's 30s
I'm not sure where this comes from but
it's sort of life-affirming
and this is shot by hank gomez in 1930
there's President Eisenhower and you're
gonna see a ticker tape parades and
campaign publicity for both um the Nixon
and the Kennedy campaigns in 1960 mr.
Gomez's
film collection is extremely extensive
and it's absolutely wonderful he took
his 8 millimeter camera everywhere and
you're gonna see a bunch of it tonight
guess the new crown Zellerbach building
and this comes to us from Rick lab sure
and these are just some floats from
parades in the 30s
[Applause]
this is almost as good as Pride today
[Applause]
um this is Henk Gomez this is
Longshoremen's Hall under construction
and you know what the Embarcadero
Freeway
[Music]
gosh what do you think 58 57 and here my
request is an old favorite hang on
[Applause]
[Applause]
there was an outtake from the 1957 film
the lineup a very rare interstate 480
sign for the Embarcadero Freeway
our working waterfront from courtesy of
filmmaker carry light Allah
that's tore from the Norwegian ship
Taurus all longshore workers the old way
pre container and a little bit of
crabbing crabbers on Fisherman's Wharf
now you you'll remember our existential
runner I've been showing him every year
because he so seems without reason and
some of you will remember that last year
I found a little bit more footage that
helps explain sort of what's going on so
since this is kind of tough to follow
we're gonna look at it again
we begin here on Grant Avenue and if you
look hard he's um he's somewhere in here
but I know this segues right into this
[Applause]
and then he runs up we don't know what
movie this is from but it's outtakes for
a reason
and take two he actually made it onto
the cable car
take two or three and it's still a bit
of a mystery
now what we're seeing now is footage
shot by Oswald Sykes in 1970 mr. Sykes
was attending the National
Rehabilitation Association conference at
the Fairmount mr. Sykes was instrumental
in organizing the National Association
of lawn white rehabilitation workers to
face down the racism in the NRA this is
Earl Caldwell Earl Caldwell was West
Coast correspondent for the New York
Times
mr. Caldwell documented the Black Power
movement in the Black Panther Party from
inside he was the only reporter
president when dr. King was assassinated
we'll see him again shortly he covered
the Angela Davis trial here he is
talking to people in the national
non-white Rehabilitation Association the
FBI tried to get him to inform he
refused and ultimately the Supreme Court
ruled against him this footage mr.
Oswald Sykes and his spouse Marion and
daughter Kim are in the audience tonight
and this is the bathtub and these are
native activists on their way to
Alcatraz Earl Caldwell embedded himself
in Alcatraz and so he would have known
these people the skipper of the bathtub
the son of the skipper in those days was
going to come tonight but he's actually
got a job he's um he's sailing a
Hornblower job in the end the bay today
but these films come to us through mr.
and mrs. Sykes daughter Kim who were
greatly indebted and she's here tonight
[Applause]
and you could still charter the bathtub
today this is Earl Caldwell in his
apartment he's drinking Coors and some
shots from his apartment on Upper
Fillmore and I've left this in because I
was curious if any of you might
recognize this man who's talking to her
al Caldwell
well I thought that too I'm not sure
this is um newly scan material of the
Fillmore Street counterbalance cable car
between green and Broadway 1939 to 1940
it was so steep that a complex
arrangement was devised where the car
going down helps to pull the car going
out and there's a little bit of
electrical assist as well so this is a
cable car with an electric motor at the
same time this is what the 22 used to
look like
thank you um dong thank revelled who I
think is with us tonight
um donated some beautiful footage of San
Francisco in 1928 this is the new marina
you can see it isn't all even built up
yet
and thanks again to Hank Gomez the San
Francisco Arts Festival of 1957 in
Washington Square this is highly
selective he shot about half an hour of
it but there's just a few things that
are especially cool today like the van
the other van some of the constructivist
and
a little bit of Bay Area tradition of
ironwork a dome and making peace with
modernism the industrial designer Expo
this was the wooden dome and a great
deal of how-to of you know involvement
for these gomes kids or any of them here
I think I just met you right
[Applause]
this is before being a maker meant you
know writing code
okay you're some students science and AV
students in the San Francisco School
District and this comes to us from dawn
Levison whose spouse Linda Levison is
Normand Rosenberg's daughter and this is
part of the king norman film collection
do any of you remember king Norman Toy
Stores so here's the a/v squad
science project
King Norman had a king Norman's TV show
is on kgo between 54 and 61 and look
with these kids built
[Applause]
and this is a field trip to the Annabel
candy company on Market Street until 65
makers of rocky road which is what
they're making that'll look bars and big
hunk bars and I want you to watch the
kids carefully
[Applause]
it sort of almost but not quite
artisanal this company is now in Hayward
it's still in business I don't think
they know I'm showing this
[Applause]
so a somewhat mysterious film from
obviously around World War two make of
it what you will I've cut it down to one
minute from about half an hour
[Applause]
and now this film was recently donated
to us by the Century Club of California
I need to thank Andrea Thurber for this
this is a film produced by mrs. SB
Buckner and members of the Century Club
and the birders are made um fulfilled
Schumann corny and Brigham and they're
spoofing bird-watching
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh a domestic duck maybe a gone
[Applause]
so you can see they're all adding to
their life lists now um we have this
film through also the courtesy of
thanks to buck and Jen from Moo vet film
transfer which is a great place to send
your home movies this is a film shot by
Gary Meyer Gary are you here tonight
maybe tomorrow it's the human BN On
January 14 1967 between twenty and
thirty thousand people were there nobody
seemed to be able to get a straight
count and I think the sort of
intoxication of the camerawork gives a
sense of the mood
is that the dad
was anybody there oh my god
and this is Ocean Avenue
and shot by Hank Gomez the visitation
nursery school parade I think late 50s
would you agree with me so this is sort
of critical mass with tricycles
[Applause]
and Twin Peaks with still a few unbuilt
areas in the landscape I don't have an
identity on this but this was shot by
Hank Gomez again it's his children in
front sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I so this is the Sunset District in 1920
I've restored this footage this turned
up in a basement on 23rd Avenue and
ivory scanned the night trade and 4k
some of you have seen poor quality
before but you can see the sunset was
not built up
and I'm gonna need your help here but
these are stone son homes being built I
think pre-world War two mr. Stinson's
you know developed stones town and I'm
not exactly sure where this is I'm
thinking maybe the lakeside area any
western neighborhoods authorities here
tonight will come back tomorrow they'll
tell you but if you live in the avenues
this is what the skeleton of your house
looks like
so I hope that the Gomez family will
help me out but here's a trip to Kaiser
hospital
we're leaving Ingleside Terrace and I'm
kind of curious why we're going to
Kaiser but watch closely because there's
something really funny in just a moment
the place where men waited while their
female partners were giving birth was
the airport
[Applause]
it's their neighbor having a baby
and thanks to the San Francisco Public
Library this is a film made by the city
for some study purpose let's take a
quick trip down Geary and back 1968
this is what the new bus rapid-transit
will offer
[Applause]
heart Presidium 16th 18th 20th years
Gaspar easy
Pacific Cafe
[Applause]
[Applause]
the weather changed in the meantime
[Applause]
you know ham bruh I know the Alexandria
karna
Sears
Kizer
in the central freeway now gone
[Applause]
and this is mrs. Gomez Claudia is that
you
this is an Ingleside Terrace
and this is the space program
San Francisco zone
[Applause]
and a little piece from David Gallagher
which probably comes from a collection
shot by the future or the feature family
this is early but early to late 40s
[Applause]
right
and since scooters have been in the news
this year we're going to revisit the
Pioneer scooter club this is a Lin wall
Vespa out on Geary and Parker and these
are scooters asserting their political
rights the Pioneer scooter club got
actually a bunch of national publicity
there's pictures in Life magazine and
one of the leaders who got a lot of
publicity was named Warren Carver I
think we're gonna see Warren as well but
this was what did we say I think this is
about 61 and it's um well you know the
hypnotist
and off they go
I think this is Warren Carver
I don't think this was all about them
and this was um shot by Oswald Sykes in
1970 on his visit to San Francisco I
think he was impressed by the footwork
and you will be as well
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
our next clip is courtesy of the San
Francisco Public Library from
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the primary is to serve the public by
all free parking in the congested
business district and to ward off any
decentralisation of business there are
160 tons reach columns supporting each
floor connected by where the real quick
support of parks is between 12 and 19
inches thick the construction is
fireproof reinforced concrete
and walked over 1 million five hundred
thousand dollars during the first year
of operations 1943 776 thousand
automobiles were parked in the year 1945
approximately 1 million cars were hunted
and today approximately 3,000 cars day
at they employ although the garage has
1500 spaces solved if necessary 1,700
cars could be parked at one time by
patience for protection from fire each
floor is equipped with eight stand pipe
connections and numerous fire
extinguishers including the newest class
many conveniences are available for
[Music]
[Applause]
checking of customers this is an
essential service because the garage
denied liability for articles left by
customers in their cars and mean for
their perfection are therefore providing
an excellent falling in baseball feeding
an employee's lunchroom has been
provided where hot spot the incentive
this may be a thing
as an added feature daily broadcast over
one of the major networks emanate from
the waiting lobby on the main floor this
program entitled only hair from Union
Square
many people interviewed for their
opinion and comments on issues of
national importance
this lovely lady [ __ ] she might find out
just how long she would have to wait for
nylon I wonder what the announcer Bob
Turner had to say to that one sentence
is going proud of the jobs been
accomplished and removing cars from the
streets of the downtown district and for
the service rendered to Hotel Plaza
theaters restaurants retail stores and
comes with the professional men in this
convenient location so that their
patrons may drive in comfort to these
places of business this is a view of one
of the outgoing Lane it seems as though
everyone wants to get home at the same
time due to the many years of mr. Fenty
needs experience and since the start of
operations of the Union Square garage
many faults have been overcome necessary
but smooth Authority you use square
garage of sentences all is the only
underground garage of its type in the
world it is successful proof that a
garage may combine duty along with an
essential burger it is the first in a
series of similar projects that have
founded develop throughout all major
cities of the world
this is a demonstration against the
Vietnam War on November 14 1969 and
although I didn't get this from him I
believe this was shot by Richard Dillman
who lives I believe in Marin some of you
may know him
um if anybody recognizes any of these
people please shout it out
and this is the hunters point housing
project seam from candlestick in 1960 to
the World Series and from Donvan reveled
the spanking-new Palace of Fine Arts
this is 1928 what's kind of interesting
about is that the Golf Course in Lincoln
Park you see the dunes are still showing
through you notice in the sand trap well
it's a literal sand trap
and some new shipwrecks this year this
is the Lyman Stuart an oil tanker in
1922 that broke up at Lands End this is
six years later and then the coos bay
which was bound from San Francisco to
coos bay Ashley counter-intuitively with
a load of lumber and hid Iraq and ran
aground in 1927 and there's still pieces
of the Lyman Stewart by the way you can
see at low tide from the coastal trail
but we usually see the Ohio and then the
Frank K buck I had never seen the coos
bay before
and then the Ohioan which was a huge
tourist attraction there were special
streetcars going out to see this this is
on October 1936 you could see the
engines are still going it it had a load
of trucks and washing machines in
general merchandise and was around for
quite a while salvage efforts are in
progress you know it's it's further out
it's beyond the Cliff House on the
coastal trail
and this is um probably 1928 it's the
Golden Gate swim this is from is from
Don Levison thank you and haven't done
much research on this yet but apparently
it was broadcast on the radio
and these are members many of these are
from the south end rowing club
[Applause]
this is a Crissy Field and to remind us
of the ephemeral nature of motion
picture film just a couple shots from a
Pittsburgh family that are delightfully
decayed
sorry no this is regular safety film and
from dawn Levison the construction of
the Golden Gate Bridge
there was so much access to that bridge
while under construction I I don't
understand everybody seems to have taken
a walk there and here we've just opened
up and you know I don't know if the
traffic is up to expectations and some
of the Gomez brothers and
and a little bit of
jnana
and finally the West most extension of
San Francisco the Farallon Islands as we
know in district 1 supervisorial
district this was shot on sometime in
the mid to late 50s no it was a ret
still it was a refuge by then thank you
so much
[Applause]
thank you everybody
[Applause]
[Music]